now in December 2017 36 year old then
FBI agent Carlos wolf got into a single
car uh accident he was standing on the
side of the interstate with Sandra Cohen
an off-duty Deputy fire chief when they
were both struck by another car the
impact through Cohen and wolf over the
median of the roadway where Cohen was
struck by a second vehicle they both
died
the driver was Roberto Garza Palacios he
was here illegally overstaying a work
visa that has expired eight years before
well his only punishment
a citation for negligent driving and a
280 dollar fine
joining me now is Marla Ingram the wife
of Carlos wolf Marla I am so sorry for
your loss and what happened here
and I know you're watching this border
issue closely today given everything
that your family went through so your
reaction to this continued cycle of
violence via what is now a fully open
border
this continued cycle of violence is
completely unacceptable Laura thank you
so much for having me on the show first
of all my heart goes out to these family
members in Texas Mr Garcia who lost his
wife and his eight-year-old son
um complete senseless acts and I am
praying for these families and I want
them to know that Jesus will carry them
through this unimaginable pain if they
allow him to he has carried my kids and
I through this pain my son was had just
turned seven and my daughter was two
years old when they lost their dad and
Jesus never left our side so that is
what I would like to say to these
families and it is I have formed just a
such a strong friendship with the
parents of sander Cohen he was a
remarkable man
Good Samaritan stopped didn't have to
stop for Carlos stop to help him and
lost his life as well and God has just
binded our two families together
and
it is shocking for me to see this
continuation of not only an open border
a president who doesn't accept
responsibility who has just recently
gone to the border to see the disaster
that he has
allowed to happen but then what what
just let me interrupt for a second
the Secretary of Homeland Security said
yesterday
that the policies were effective given
the resources they have
effective
your reaction to just that word being
used
absolutely
it's ludicrous
and we need to see
the you know half of the border patrol
agents as you know Laura are Hispanic so
to try to say that this is a racial
issue my husband was Hispanic and to try
to spend that the policies have been
completely ineffective we have millions
of immigrants coming across the border
as you know the drugs the the child
trafficking and all of these horrific
crimes and then we have
immigrants killing other immigrants so
this is not even what the Hispanic
Community wants
and I am just the sanctuary cities so
Roberto Garza Palacios he was wanted by
Ice two times just three months before
he killed Carlos and sander three months
ice wanted him for a second time but
because of Montgomery County Maryland's
Sanctuary policies they let him out they
they refused to hold them so it is
having such an important Montgomery
Montgomery County Maryland locked all
the kids down during covid a total
nightmare but the people keep voting for
the same leadership they voted for that
Ehrlich to get you know re-elected as
you know the county executive there but
it's a disaster Montgomery County
Maryland is a disaster thank you for
sharing your story your husband's story
a beautiful family and you lost your
husband and your children lost their
father uh and we appreciate you coming
on tonight thank you thank you Laura
thank you so much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else